plus je venais avec - venez avec moi on
va prendre vie vous êtes sous dialyse
parce que là il va y passer la brosse
est sous dialyse ou pas n'ont pas le
beau jeu au point d'un rail a pas de
problème des champions bordeaux non
honnêtement non on va perdre la prison
voulait pas qu'on prenne un bond à bout
de gros colon il me faut j'ai besoin de
fabriquer un anus artificiel en qui tu
connais moi vous que l'on à bout
d'intestin mademoiselle tandis que le
groupe dit madame super d'un groupe non
match et non pas si vous faites du rock
je vous demande de vous êtes de quel
groupe sanguin c'est qu'on fait ce sens
ah oui mais je vous demande pas de
donner je vous ordonne de me donner ma
lin venez avec moi c'est une question de
vie ou de mort
j'ai envie de vomir mon pouvoir
on va vous êtes père est là parce que le
fenouil oui venez avec moi empêcher une
petite aviation vient là pour cinq
minutes et donné la tétée comment foulée
du boulot il faut absolument repérer
tout de suite
vous êtes de quel que soit le vous venez
avec moi je fais un petit de transfusion
la maisonnée avec moi j'ai un client m'a
dit non mais madame il va mourir mais
j'ai loupé l'aorte
pourquoi claqué la porte au nez la
voisine en jeu le professeur teresa
champ d'opération foyer mais bon j'ai un
petit peu ce que j'ai mon assistant de
thé party simplement d'être mignonne
elle est partie déféquer et puis comment
ce moment là un petit peu sur les nerfs
y en a pour 20 minutes ou moins que
mercy comme ça vous êtes mignonne
merci je vous appelle tout à l'heure
pour faire pipi voilà vous êtes de quel
groupe s'il vous plaît vous êtes de
groupe sanguin
à vous de dire que c'est une fausse
bonne opération
alors c'est à dire bien naturellement
qui s'est écrasé là devant personne peut
donner du sens presque que c'est un
chien on va pas laisser crever comme un
homme était la gérante des foules
après vous voulez faire d'accord y'a pas
de problème il a perdu un testicule
alcan pour le remplacer mais si on va
prendre un bout d'intestin bout en bout
d'intestin ici en somme une paupiette on
va faire comme une paupiette l'animal
comme ça il sera pas défigurée
dépêchez vous c'est un berger allemand
super ce sera vraiment conquis lit pas
sur les benêts monsieur ben finalement
vite vous êtes du même coup le sanguin
en berger allemand et alors c'est mon
chien va pas le laisser crever non
[Musique]
le transsexuel c'est beau venez vite on
a le donneur la venez vite on a on à
l'andouillette
c'est beau transsexuel c'est pas vous
revoir monsieur g merci d'avoir choisi
de voir qu'est ce que j'ai à faire
barman avant la prochaine comme serré la
main en fait un bisou
au revoir et merci d'avoir choisi
lariboisière je travaille moi et pour
être sûr de ne rien rater de nos
latitudes abonnez vous il m'était
impossible ou